[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 47th
episode of chess trap series
in this episode i am going to show you a
wonderful
high profile trap in the baltic defense
from the white perspective the critical
position arises
after the following opening mortar d4
d5 knight to f3 and now
because white hasn't committed the move
c4
black can take the advantage and play
the move
bishop to f5 so black planning of
campaign is very obvious
he wants to play the move e6 c6
where his bishop is outside the pawn
chain
okay we have some natural moves c4
trying to destroy the center as well as
looking for the queen b3 idea
so accordingly e6 is not a good choice
by the black
and that's why the majority of the games
continue with
c6 so that when
white played the move queen to b3 which
attacks on b7 black can simply defend
everything with queen to b6
well now if you exchange the queen then
resulting position is quite playable for
the black camp
so accordingly the best move in this
position is
c captures d5 which sets up a
very nice strap
well here many black players has
delighted
because they can immediately destroy
white pawn structure
with queen captures b3 and after a
captures b3
you can already see white has some
fracture pawns on the b
file and since the queens are exchanged
this is a huge positional win by the
black camp
well yes to some extent it is true
but chess is a tricky game and believe
it or not
but now it is black who is really
asking for the trouble for example
if he plays the natural move such as c
catches d5
then white can continue with knight to
c3
attacking the pawn and it doesn't matter
whether black continue with
e6 or knight to f6 the next move is a
killer one
knight to b5 looking at
juicy c7 folk and the most
interesting part is black can never play
the move a6 and kick this knight out
because a pawn is completely pinned down
so all in all with this monster knight
this is a huge advantageous position
for the white camp
that's why at this position rather than
capturing the spawn
many wise black players has sensed the
danger
and continue with bishop captures b1
which is in fact as per the database
played in more than 25 games
and you might think black has solved all
his problem right
nope as he straight away fallen
into our trappy territory as our trappy
business start with this
dazzling peace sacrifice d capture c6
so white doesn't bother about regaining
the peace
but rather he is more interested on the
black queen side
now here if black routinely capture on
c6
let's say knight capture c6 then we can
take on b1
and even though we have a double pawn
it's an extra pawn
and sooner or later this will definitely
count
in the end game so that's not a good
choice by the black camp
but many of you will ask hang on
isn't black can save the piece and same
time
defend on b7 with this spectacular
bishop to e4
well this is exactly the case where most
of the game
gone into this direction not only black
has saved the piece
but dealing with all the thread so now
if c captures b7 then black has bishop
captures b7
and if white continue with c7
then black can respond with knight to c6
saving all the threats
so does it means that white has made a
big blunder
of course not as after white's next
reply
more or less black can resign the game
so before i move on guys i want you to
pause this video and find out
that killer move which wins the game
outright
are you ready i hope you indeed see
this deciding blow boom
what a moo well black rook doesn't have
any square to go so he has to accept
this
p sacrifice by white but
now you will see the point behind
sacrificing
two piece as white can simply respond
with
c7 and that pawn is literally
shouting somebody stopped me
there are two ways white can promote to
queen and
unfortunately for black he cannot stop
both of it after some natural moves
knight to c6 c8 equals queen and knight
to d8
if you carefully count the material
white emerge
with a queen and two pawn against rook
canaanite
which is definitely a huge winning
advantage
for the ycam
so this is one of the high profile trap
exist
in the baltic defense which you
definitely want to consider
in the tournament practice
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
nice trap in the baltic defense remember
when you open and continue with bishop
captures b1
do not grab the piece but give your
opponent this root
shock with d capture c6 and after the
obvious move bishop to e4
the deciding blow rook captures a7
gives white a early victory just within
the opening stage
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care